♪ ♪
>> Tammy: NOW THE DESTRUCTIVE
DEMOCRAT AGENDA IS SAILING ON
ALL FRONTS AND NOWHERE IS IT
MORE APPARENT THAN IN OUR
DEMOCRAT-RUN FAR LEFT CITIES.
FOR EXAMPLE OUT CALIFORNIA
HOMICIDES JUMPED 31% LAST YEAR.
IN SAN FRANCISCO A NEW SURVEY
FINDS THAT THE CITY IS ON TRACK
TO LOSE NEARLY HALF ITS
RESIDENTS IN THE YEARS TO COME.
AND IN MINNEAPOLIS, GET THIS, A
JUDGE HAS ORDERED THE CITY TO
HIRE MORE POLICE OFFICERS AFTER
RULING IN FAVOR OF A GROUP THAT
SUED THE CITY COUNCIL OVER
SURGING CRIME.
AND PERHAPS MORE TRAGIC OF ALL
IS IN CHICAGO WHERE WEEKEND
AFTER WEEKEND, DOZENS UPON
DOZENS OUR SHOTS.
OVER 1,500 SO FAR THIS YEAR.
BUT FAILED HIM HERE
LORI LIGHTFOOT IS STILL REFUSING
TO TAKE ANY RESPONSIBILITY FOR
HER FAR LEFT FEELINGS AND IS
BLAMING IT ALL ON, GET THIS,
RACISM AND SEXISM.
>> MAYOR, IN RECENT MONTHS THERE
HAVE BEEN QUESTIONS RAISED ABOUT
YOUR TEMPERAMENT AND YOUR
REACTION TO CRITICISM, AN
EDITORIAL USED THE TERM
"IRASCIBLE."
HOW MUCH OF THIS DO YOU THINK
MIGHT HAVE TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT YOU ARE A WOMAN AND IS
TYPICALLY A BLACK WOMAN?
>> ABOUT 99% OF IT.
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
ALWAYS HELD TO DIFFERENT
STANDARDS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT, I HAVE KNOWN
THAT MY WHOLE LIFE.
>> Tammy: -- SO ASK YOURSELF,
HOW IS IT THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
CLAIM TO CARE ABOUT LIVES AND
OUR URBAN AREAS OF THE SAME ONES
FUELING POLICIES THAT MAKE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE WORSE AND WORSE.
NEVER ENDING ATTACKS ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT, FAR LEFT
SOCIALISM, GOVERNMENT
DEPENDENCY, ALL WHILE TAKING NO
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE HUMAN
SUFFERING AND THE HUMAN TOLL,
THE LOSS OF LIFE AND THE LOSS OF
HUMAN DIGNITY.
TAKING PLACE ON THEIR WATCH,
MONTH AFTER MONTH, FRANKLY IT IS
DISGRACEFUL.
THE FAR LEFT WASHINGTON MACHINE
AND THEIR ALLIES IN THE MEDIA
ARE LEAVING THESE COMMUNITIES
BEHIND.
HOW OFTEN DO YOU HEAR THE NAMES
OF THE VICTIMS OF SHOOTINGS IN
THOSE DAYS?
WHY AREN'T THERE PROTESTS FOR
THOSE LIVES?
AND WHY AREN'T THERE MASSIVE
FUND-RAISING CAMPAIGNS FOR THOSE
FAMILIES, BECAUSE IT'S THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY REALLY DON'T CARE AT ALL.
THEY LOVE HAVING THE ISSUE, THAT
LOVE STOKING THE DIVISION, THEY
LOVE RAISING THE MONEY AND THEY
NEVER ACTUALLY WANT TO FIND A
SOLUTION AND THE WORST PART, IT
IS ALL BY DESIGN.
BECAUSE THEY ARE FRAUDS, THEY
ARE GRIFTERS, AND THEY COULDN'T
BE LESS INTERESTED IN DELIVERING
REAL RESULTS FOR POOR AND
WORKING AMERICANS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
JOINING ME FOR ACTION, CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEY LEO TERREL AND
"OUTNUMBERED" COHOST
EMILY COMPAGNO.
THIS HAS TO BE, EMILY, ONE OF
THE MORE SHOCKING THINGS.
I WANT WOMEN TO BE IN OFFICE,
ONE ALL KINDS OF PEOPLE TO HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN GOVERNING CITIES
AND THIS IS WHAT TRIBAL POLITICS
DOES.
DESTROYING A CITY AND THEN SHE
BLAMES RACISM AND SEXISM.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> I AGREE WITH YOU AND IT'S
ALSO DISINGENUOUS.
SHE CAMPAIGNED OVER TWO YEARS
AGO ON DIMINISHING THE
UNYIELDING VIOLENCE IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF CHICAGO.
SHE KNEW EXACTLY WHAT SHE WAS
GETTING INTO ONLY TO SEE IT
SPIKE 15% HER SECOND YEAR, THE
HOMICIDES.
THEN AFTER MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND WEEK DOMINIC LAST MONTH,
SHE SAID IT'S A BLOODBATH AND
UNACCEPTABLE ONLY NOW IN THE
FACE OF CRITICISM, RIGHTLY SO,
IN THE PUBLIC OUTCRY SHE CALLS
IT ALL OF A SUDDEN RACIST AND
SEXIST WHEN SHE HERSELF CAME OUT
FROM THE BEGINNING TO SAY SHE
SHOULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
WE ALL KNOW FROM HER INTERNAL
EMAILS -- RUNS THIS TOXIC OFFICE
IS ANYTHING LESS THAN WHAT IS
FLOWING FROM HER BUT SHE IS
LETTING DOWN THE COMMUNITY, YOUR
POINT, TAMMY, AND THE LOSS OF
LIVES.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE LOSS OF LIVES
THIS PAST WEEKEND, A
ONE-MONTH-OLD.
>> Tammy: IT IS HEARTBREAKING
AND IT IS HORRIFIC.
LEO, WE'VE GOT A DYNAMIC HERE
WHERE WE CLAIM AND WE KNOW THE
PEOPLE OF COLOR, WOMEN, MEN,
EVERYBODY CAN BE AS GREAT AS A
COUNTERPART OR AS BAD.
WE KNOW THIS FOR A FACT AND YET,
HERE SHE IS.
SHE RAN AS A REFORMER,
SHOCKINGLY, AS EMILY REALLY LAID
OUT IN THE LIVES THAT ARE BEING
LOST, TRULY, ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
ARE BROWN AND BLACK COMMUNITIES
BEING DESTROYED AND SHE SEEMS TO
JUST BE FINE WITH THAT.
HOW IS THIS POSSIBLE?
>> JUST LOOK AT THIS PANEL RIGHT
HERE.
DIVERSITY.
WOMEN, BLACK.
SHE TRIES TO SPEAK, TAMMY, FOR
ALL OF US WHICH I REJECT.
SHE SAID WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE TREATED TO DIFFERENT
STANDARDS.
THAT'S A LIE.
SHE'S TRYING TO HIDE AND CONCEAL
HER INCOMPETENCE BY SAYING THAT
BLACKS AND WOMEN ARE AT A
DISADVANTAGE.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I DON'T SEE A DISADVANTAGE TO
YOU, TAMMY OR EMILY.
THEY DID IS A LIE AND WHAT IS SO
SAD AS SHE PLAYS THE RACE CARD
AND SHE IS IN CHARGE OF THE
SYSTEM.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT, PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE BEING KILLED AND YET
THE ATTENTION TO IT IS BEING
DISREGARDED.
OAKLAND MAYOR, OAKLAND POLICE
CHIEF WAS BEGGING THE OAKLAND
CITY COUNCIL, DON'T CUT THE
FUNDS.
I NEED THE MONEY.
THEY CUT IT ANYWAY.
DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE ABOUT
PEOPLE OF COLOR, THEY USE THEM
AS PAWNS AND YET THEIR LIVES ARE
WORTHLESS AND THAT IS WHAT YOU
SEE IN CHICAGO AND IN ALL THESE
DEMOCRATIC CITIES.
IT IS SHAMEFUL, TAMMY.
>> Tammy: THE OAKLAND EXAMPLE
IS PERFECT, INCREDIBLY ELOQUENT
PLEA FROM THAT MAN ABOUT WHAT
MATTERED IN A COMMUNITY AND THIS
IS WHAT TRIBALISM DOES COME OF
THIS IS WHAT IDENTITY POLITICS
DOES AND IT'S BEING USED NOW
AGAINST PEOPLE WHO WERE TRAINED
INTO BELIEVING THIS WOULD BE
THEIR SALVATION.
LOOK, LET'S ADMIT IT, IT'S CLEAR
I THINK IN PEOPLE'S LIVES, THERE
IS A DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCE
FOR BLACK MEN, THAT IS A
DIFFERENT LIFE EXPERIENCE FOR
GAY PEOPLE, FOR WOMEN WHO ARE
PERCEIVED TO BE WOMEN OF COLOR.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE BUT IF WE
MAKE EXCUSES AND ALLOW
POLITICIANS TO RUIN OUR LIVES
AND THEN TO BLAME SOMETHING ELSE
WHEN IT IS THEIR INCOMPETENCE WE
ARE NOT GOING TO MAKE ANY
HEADWAY ON ANY OF THESE ISSUES.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT IN THERE
AND OAKLAND WHERE I WAS BORN THE
POLICE CHIEF CALLED IT A CRISIS,
THE SAME WORD USED BY THE
LIEUTENANT MAYOR AND THE POLICE
CHIEF IN SEATTLE WHERE I
CURRENTLY LIVE, THEY SAID IT WAS
A PUBLIC CRISIS THERE, DEFENDING
THE ERODING OF THE POLICE RANKS,
THE UNILATERAL DEFUNDING OF THE
BUDGET.
WE SAW AS WELL THE JUDGE THAT IS
IN CHARGE OF THE CONSENT DEGREE,
SAID IT TOOK THEM TWO STEPS
BACK, WHAT WERE YOU THINKING OF
DOING THIS UNILATERALLY?
YOU HAVE SET BACK MEANINGFUL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM BY DOING
THIS.
WE SAW THE SAME THING IN
PORTLAND.
A UNILATERAL DEFUNDING OF THE
POLICE.
THE MAYOR BAGGED TO REFUND AND
THE CITY COUNCIL WOULDN'T EVEN
HEAR AT THE HEARING THE TOPIC ON
THE FLOOR.
THEY HAD TO RESTORE FUNDS
INSTEAD TO PARK RANGERS, TO
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THE PEOPLE SUFFERING THE MOST IN
CHICAGO, 73% OF THOSE HOMICIDES
ARE YOUNG BLACK MEN AS WELL.
IT'S THE YOUTH SUFFERING.
>> Tammy: GREAT POINT AND LEO,
WE ARE TALKING TONIGHT ABOUT
WALKING PEOPLE DO LOCALLY.
WE'VE SEEN THEM GO TO THE SCHOOL
BOARD MEETINGS BUT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT, AS EMILY NOTED ABOUT THE
CITY COUNCIL, PEOPLE HAVE GOT TO
START GOING TO THE CITY COUNCIL
TO BE HEARD BECAUSE I THINK A
LOT OF THESE LOCAL ENTITIES HAVE
NOT NECESSARILY HEARD FROM THEIR
CITIZENS.
>> I THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT, WE'VE GOT TO START SMALL.
A SMALL CITY COUNCIL SCHOOL
BOARDS, THEY TAKE OVER THE
DEMOCRATIC CITIES WHICH HAVE
BEEN IN CONTROL FOR OVER 50
YEARS AND YOU SEE THE
DESTRUCTION AND THE POVERTY IN
THESE DEMOCRATIC CITIES.
WE'VE GOT TO START SMALL AND
WORK OUR WAY UP.
I AGREE WITH YOUR PREVIOUS
PANEL, WE'VE GOT TO TAKE OVER IN
2022 ON A NATIONAL LEVEL.
>> Tammy: HAS TO BE ALL OF
THIS, IT IS NOT A ZERO-SUM GAME,
IT IS EVERYTHING.
ON THIS FOURTH OF JULY WEEKEND
WE ASSERT THAT WE ARE THE
SOVEREIGN, WE MUST BEGIN TO ACT
WITHIN THE STRUCTURE OF WHAT THE
FOUNDERS EXPECTED, WHICH WAS
INVOLVEMENT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND OF COURSE, THE